in this short video we'll talk about the
micro rnas micro rnas are class of
non-coding RNA that play important role
in regulating gene expression so the
major function for micro RNA are
involved getting involved in the gene
regulation Network
so micro rnas are associated with
development of an organ let's say brain
it is involved in cancer it is also
involved in regulation of large Gene
networks we'll talk about all of these
in this video
so first let's see how micro rnas work
so there are dedicated genes in our
genome for the micro rnas so these Gene
doesn't encode a protein but they encode
a micro RNA so the first transcript that
comes out of these kind of genes are
known as primary micro RNA transcript
and these primary microorganic
transcript get further processed with
the help of enzymes known as drosha and
dgcr8 or Pasha
so the the pre micro RNA transcript gets
further trimmed
eventually this particular pre-micro RNA
transcript would be moving out of the
nucleus with the help of the exporting 5
complex as shown here
once outside in the cytoplasm it would
be assembled with several other proteins
known as dicer and dicer further chops
off this kind of loop structure at the
end
and now there are two strands of these
micro RNA which would eventually be
associated with Argonaut proteins and it
will eventually form the risk complex or
rnai silencing complex only one strand
of these micro RNA would be loaded into
the rnai silencing complex it binds to
specific region of the MRNA and most of
the cases it lead to degradation of the
MRNA
this is how overall micro RNA can work
but there are many aspects to it like
the production of microorganic would be
way more complicated that we have seen
right now so at a simplest level there
could be one micro RNA from one
particular micro RNA Gene there could be
also multiple micro RNA or an array of
micro RNA coming out from one Gene and
later on they are getting processed
there could be also micro RNA as a part
of an intron in a protein coding Gene so
all these possibilities are there in a
live cell
question is where does Micro RNA binds
micro RNA can possibly bind to different
uh untranslated regions
most commonly they prefer the three
prime untranslated region
and some of the cases though rare they
can also bind to the five Prime
untranslated region
but that's much less frequent
so how does Micro RNA regulate gene
expression then microorganic and regular
gene expression in two ways first of all
it can down regulate the MRNA by
degrading it just by associated with the
rnai silencing complex it can chop off
the MRNA and thereby less MRNA would be
available to produce protein so less
product would be formed
there is also another way by which micro
RNA can work that is interfering with
the translation some of the cases the
microorganic and the risk complex sits
in a through three prime utr let's say
but does not cleave the MRNA
so it works like a road block for the
ribosome
or it interferes with the translation
process that is also possible
now let me tell you that micro rnas are
present in a tissue specific and cell
specific manner so let's say there are
different cell types like epithelial
cell one micro RNA might not be present
in this cell but might be present in
neuron and so might not be present in
fibroblast again so there could be
specific micro RNA which are very cell
type specific but there could be also
micro RNA which are present in pretty
much all the cell types so depending on
these function and availability micro
RNA regulate the overall Gene regulatory
networks in different cell types so how
does that happen so imagine from a stem
cell we have two alternate possibilities
one epithelial cell one neuron now there
are two Master regulatory Network here
shown by Master regulator one and two so
these Master Regulators are
transcription factor and these
transcription each of these
transcription Factor regulates one
particular gene expression module and
each of these module actually suppress
each other that's why in the stem cell
State none of the Fate is acquired so
one of the module has to dominate over
the other module this is how the system
is laid off and here comes the micro RNA
imagine a micro RNA
which is let's say micro RNA X this can
suppress the master regulator Network 2.
so as a result the master regulator
transcription Factor would be produced
less
the gene module 2 would be poorly
regulated or down regulated so now the
repression of module 2 over module 1
would be
would be gone and now module one would
be the predominant gene expression
module mediated by Master regulator one
so it might lead to the
fate towards an epithelial cell
so this is how we saw how one possible
way by which microorganic and regulate
the selfie choice
micro RNA not only is present in the
cell but also present in secreted body
fluids for example micro rnas can be
found in cerebrospinal fluid one example
is micro RNA 204 and it has been shown
by scientists recently that
microorganate 204 regulates the
quiescence of stem cells in the brain
region so it regulates the number of
quiescent neuronal stem cells and that
is super important for brain development
micro rnas are also implicated in the
context of cancer small RNA sequencing
from the tumor some samples has
identified there are several several
micro rnas which gets upregulated in a
cancer sample how does they regulate
proliferation or cell division kinetics
is something to note in the future years
and but Micro rnas are super important
in context of many diseases including
cancer
so let's ask that how one can study
micro RNA experimentally
so micro RNA can be detected with the
help of small RNA sequencing but that's
expensive so if you have you have to
know about few microorganas let's say
four or five micro rnas quantitative
real-time PCR could be another
alternative and very sensitive
also fluorescence in situ hybridization
can show you the intrinsic localization
of a particular micro RNA inside the
cell
there are reporter assets as well in
this reported assay there would be a
reported Gene like gfp underneath the
reporter the three prime utr of a Target
MRNA would be provided anyway this
reporter would be eventually transcribed
and translated to give rise to gfp but
imagine there is a micro RNA which binds
to the three prime utr and degrades this
particular this particular mRNA
so in that context less amount of gfp
would be produced so by looking at the
gfp fluorescence one can get an idea
about the regulation of micro RNA for
this particular transcript
and this is how one can possibly study
micro RNA in the lab
so I hope this video was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up you can get more notes flash cards in
my Facebook page also in Instagram
please support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via PayPal paytm or
UPI
see you in next video